[Music]
what the [ __ ] is a partridge who gives a
tree who's responsible for digging a
hole for the tree or these turtledoves
the same decorations that mr. Duncan
gave Kevin McAllister and hold on to are
they the living wing things that [ __ ] on
cars in the parking lot I mean these
franchisee they sound delicious they're
alive aren't they wait who exactly is
cooking these French ends where are our
birds today at least come in cages are
the calling birds gonna repeat
everything I say who needs five golden
you know what never mind I'm okay with
that
what's the shipping cost on six geese
a-laying wood UPS or FedEx be able to
guarantee the moment of alayan does this
true love understand that geese are mean
bastards and [ __ ] everywhere these ones
that are supposedly ass women what are
they a swimming in do they come with
their own cutie pools are we supposed to
assume this person has a lake readily
accessible are you supposed to tip the
delivery guy who in their right mind
wants 23 Birds we're supposed to feed
these things do the maids a-milking come
with cows or is it more like a bring
your own cows situation there's a [ __ ]
ton of milk make for an appropriate gift
for your true love how much milk can one
person consume before it's spoil well
what are the neighbors thinking at this
point Oh does PETA feel about this song
what kind of dance we talking about
tango waltz jazz swing salsa Charleston
bolero flamingo hustle wine tap rumba
polka Foxtrot belly ballet break erotic
my widdle Lord make themselves readily
available for freelance weeping
contracts is bleep any big business what
kind of pipes we talking about flutes
clarinets four quarters you really need
a leaven Piper just wouldn't like three
or four or be good
what is this drum line playing because I
swear to God if it's this goddamn song
I'll lose my mind do the musicians take
requests do the Lords leap to the music
who set these outrageously unrealistic
has been a Christmas cold hard the
corner it's just repeating everything
like hearing what is just remotely
thoughtful about these gifts we sit
around and just want to be a sickest six
different types of birds do you need to
feed all these people how much would
this whole thing cost wait wait wait
do you get these gifts each day
isn't that a hundred and eighty-four
Birds and 140 random maids ladies Lords
pipers and drummers what the [ __ ] is a
person supposed to do with 184 bird
[Music]